so hello Tim fam thank you very much for
coming in the mini just 48 hours before
the lib dem leader is announced now the
book is to believe and the grass would
oppose me to leave that you are going to
have succeeded clay as leader of the
party if that's the case what will be
the first thing you do on Friday I'm on
Friday we will have known by some time
by then so I guess a lot of stuff will
be done on Thursday itself a lot of
people say thank you to first of all I
think all of it is organizational and a
lot of it is about those making sure we
get our message across in a neatly away
organization leave the Liberal Democrats
and the leaders office is traditionally
been in Westminster in the parliament
frankly it shouldn't be so the leaders
of his room it's me and move over to HQ
because the colorful different centers
of power now we need to be working very
closely together as we
but that is all part and parcel of
trying to measure communicate message so
amongst the things that we're doing very
is getting on across a message which is
not monster but is all about challenging
this government on the thing that it's
doing and providing more colorful more
exciting alternative if you're
successful in the leadership contest
them by what magic would we judge it
successful you know how many MPs would
you like to see in 2020 what is going to
be because you've talked about turning
the part in Leicester traditional
political party more of a campaign force
how do you say that's been good or bad
well it's a good question enough for my
part I think I'm not planning to tell
you what numbers of MPs we may consider
to be a possible more good with more
than a smaller than a i think is a
reasonable assessment but I think
will be foolish of me not leasing the
boundary changes in your point playing I
certainly think my job you to take us
out teams and to create a platform
insensitive on whose side we are what
our purposes into that position where
we're on double figures team I team very
higher in terms of percentage points for
the party that's all about establishing
purposes why should people give it a
second round watch their back foot and
that I was in the first class of the
post and that entails was then
campaigning on the ground to turn up
eighteen nineteen percent the road when
I get into 40 45 50 was in the boat in
particular areas so we can win elections
what would you do differently to leader
as an eclair well I think I'm in a
totally different landscape and so
anything that I do is bound to be based
upon a personal characteristics of my
ambitions in the party but also the
place we find ourselves and so I think
in Nick letters immensely well
late two thousand seven through the barn
Malcolm and Eddie period Goodman misty
he has now stepped down in a different
situation I and I suppose my job is to
be a campaigning leader is to be
somebody who takes and bumps if you like
of our reduced situation but actually
means that believe it slummin believe it
can not have to worry about being
we've seen it every single parliamentary
functional events go on to values which
is another thing has been and so one of
the things that he said of course
controversy was about saying there
should be a lesbian couple on Peppa Pig
and when he was in the mini and he said
to me it's because people and get this
sense of attraction to the same stuff
some of your same-sex at a very young
age do you agree with him on that I
think it's kind of I'm against
politicians meddling in the lady so the
owns that the point is trying to mind
but I think that we all do mean it again
giving up boys too
the children's programs with the news 9
and we're going to leave
I understandable he's making about
tonight absolutely
it's awesome
politicians well on the topic of
same-sex marriage which is again to
cause some disruption between the two of
people talk about your respective voting
records and that sort of thing that I
put this question to him enough with tee
off so you both have liberal valium
lodging in Liberal Democrats but do you
think there's any contradiction someone
having strong Christian buyers and also
a little bit no not at all
leaving I think that Charles Kennedy in
Asian to me Catholic and serves only to
successfully
seven years and and throughout time
managed to get the balance right
Christianity faith in general it isn't
in time but you have no I don't think I
liberal to impose
chaya to the Charles was a great example
you don't run thing they'll people so
and yet you do attempt a little those
bunnies
and for the members of the probably
having big buttons can't have no idea
who you are right a lot of people around
finally morning Thursday they discover
you're the new leader of the Liberal
Democratic what's your message to those
people what's the point of view what's
the point of the Liberal Democrats well
I want to make sure that the limit
perhaps our party the people of the view
that they can go more again and
understand that when the party ends
living in the country
defending and I want to build that
genuine liberal movement nationalism
wherever it is actually Scotland
actually new kid nationalism across
other parts of Europe to be and frankly
we are in a situation seven yet optum
bishop has gone up
he was listeners leaders